peuvent avoir
quitter la loire qui est on rentre dans
le terroir de bons gates
on va traverser un grande restigné c'est
le début de l'appellation cette plaine
donne soif alors de la dgde que j'aille
là je suis en condition dire que l'âge
vraiment j'ai jamais je peux même dire
que la soif me prend après langer ce
qu'ils soient celles qu'on est là
maintenant j'arrive sur eux sur le
premier paysage de bombay selon l'église
qu'on a vu de loin
il disait tout une histoire parce que le
clocher de l'église a été décollées par
une
par un coup de foudre au
les années 30 et puis dans l'aperçu à
l'abbaye tous et maintenant on va
rentrer d'un sur la place de l'école
la housse planter des circuits voile à
l'école c'est la tête et à l'école alors
j'en ai profité ma première école
réellement il est absolument rien ne
changerait y avait trois places là il y
avait la classe maternelle
il y avait une seconde classe là elle
quitter la classe des moyens puis après
la classe la classe du certificat
d'études qui était la grande place
maintenant tout ça avoue s'agrandir et
puis il ya puis dans le fond il y avait
il y avait une espèce de gymnase dans le
fond à droite qui doit toujours exister
et puis à baver les cabinets oui amélie
foulon et ça a changé sa vie mais oui ça
a dû se modernise et parce que j'ai
aperçu de nogent-le-roi d'aisance
depuis la maison des maîtres est pour
moi la maison des maîtres c'est drôle
parce que quand on songera évoque dans
les souvenirs pour moi c'est un peu la
maison des chuteurs du grand moun ah oui
oui exactement ce qu'ils ont fait pour
moi il ya quelque chose d'alain fournier
là dedans
non que c'est dans cette école là quand
j'ai vu grand monde pour la première
fois j'ai tout de suite eu la sensation
d'avoir vécu dans les lieux parce que
autrefois aussi il y avait sur cette
place des cires que puisse installer des
petits cirques
et les les enfants des gens du voyage
venaient à l'école pendant une journée
alors si d'une chose c'était un excitant
ce d'imagination voilà c'est là que j'ai
appris à lire cela que je fais les bat
on l'agité ya une chose tout à fait
étonnante
j'y suis venu il ya quelques années ici
est survenu vers 1
un interview ici les quelques années qui
rentre dans la classe il y avait la même
odeur de crêpes épaisses de choses et à
cette piste de son secret d'encre et
c'est une belle idée dernier le vix
monde où j'ai pu retrouver sa jeunesse
que tu gardes des bons souvenirs de tes
années d'écoliers tellement oui mais les
meilleures années de ma vie c'est mes
années de classe
quoi qu'il arrive parce que c'était tu
sais je sens de gel sont aujourd hui je
le sens très copains et tout ça dès
qu'il ya une agglomération y avait pas
d'école mixte à l'époque mais dès qu'il
ya une espèce d'agglomération masculine
je me sens tout à fait à mon aise ça
c'est le début du temps des copains pour
moi l'école
et j'ai fait très mauvaise l'étude
mais j'ai un souvenir de foot mais elle
est vécue et même de mes vicissitudes
pendant des années d'études c'est
totalement non non seulement totalement
vivant mais c'est un grand apport pour
moi dans dans ma vie actuelle et dans
si tu ou sinon employant moins de grands
dans dans mon inspiration sur mon métier
d'acteur je suis un petit peu marqué par
ce
d'abord parce que ce que j'en ai
beaucoup parlé et parce que j'en suis
fier j'en suis totalement orgueilleux de
cette région et du stade de ce que je
ressens thibault doit énormément à cette
région doit énormément le fait d'être un
fils d'homme 2 20 et 2 ans fils de
région de vin une ça donne une salle
heures ce sont des pays qui excite
l'imagination
on avait deux fois par an au théâtre à
tour la forêt var de l'opérette et on
allait voir les toujours les mêmes
pièces d'ailleurs rarement d'ivoire la
veuve joyeuse et très intense à vendre
hummer c'était un truc me lis classe
avant tout à l'heure mais mon père était
un spectateur extrêmement curieux c'est
il allait toujours le théâtre avec une
paire de jumelles et son goût à lui
c'était de reconnaître en dedans les
acteurs et dans les figurants d'une
choriste de la pièce
la seconde pièce et les 28 jours de
direct de mon père aimait retrouver des
ressemblances avec les gens du pays
ainsi il y avait un grainetier à
bourgueil qui s'appelait souligné qu'ils
avaient une grande barbe
il y avait parmi ces les parmi les
choristes il y avait un personnage qui
avait une grande barbe et mon père crier
en terre pas retenu ses solos niais et
c'était où il y avait toujours pour lui
le le grand charme d'une représentation
théâtrale c'est de retrouver une
ressemblance avec une de ses
connaissances locales
[Musique]
je le vire laden par exemple le portail
que vous voyez là alors c'est peut-être
aussi le la première caméra de la
famille me permets de vous expliquer
pourquoi ce que mon père était très
curieux et mon père il y avait un trou
dans la dent dans le portail pour le
bois de portail et là à travers le trou
mais regardez ce qui se passe est
dispensé pas grand chose il ya le moins
de mouvements que maintenant le village
était beaucoup plus petit que maintenant
et il disait toujours tu tiens des il
est 14h45 par exemple c'est l'heure où
notion at elle doit passer quand il y
avait cinq ou six minutes de retard
quand il y avait cinq ou six minutes de
retard le
c'était un incident qui faisait que la
journée prenait à un tour tout à fait
particulier et mon père faisait les gros
plans sur le sur les individus qui
passait tout le temps et il avait à la
suite de ça parce qu'il y avait quelques
fois de l'ère que passer par le trou est
monté avec volontiers une offre tel
middle ski regarder par le trou de ce
portail
maintenant le monde est mort il ya deux
ans mais ce qui est peut être c'est
qu'il ya encore quelques années on lit
il y avait toujours bourré de ricard
monte sur la boutique ils l'ont fait
repeindre la cambre soeur a vendu mais
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire tomber les
chaînons maintenant boire un coup
maintenant oui les amuse la tête d'aller
au certes comme ça ils verraient là y
verrez la boule de feu on va y connaît
statut peut boire un coup de 76 76 je
voyais pas ça y est vous arrive à le
chambrer un peu pour qu'ils soient il en
est de 73 pour qu'il soit aura fallu
l'ouvrir aurait fallu nourrir les vins
chez nous ça toujours été un voyage dans
lequel on pouvait reconnaître le pollen
d'une dalle insectes qui s'est déposé
sur sur une grappe ça on le cern
toujours ça et puis on dit toujours que
tel c'est à dire que le vin évolue d'un
d'un qui n'est même pas un kilomètre
mais deux à trois cents mètres le
l'éclairage sange le terrain change la
main du viticulteur n'est pas la même
dans le vin est quelque chose de tête il
ya un voyage permanent dans le vin quand
on sait boire et quand c'est du bon vin
il ya des saloperies innommable dans
lequel on peut même penser aux autres
il n'y a rien qui vous fait rêver mais
le fait une véritable déglutition
vinicole c'est quelque chose quand on
dit les gens disent bon quand on attend
d'ailleurs ça me donne soif votre
histoire là maintenant ça va commencer
peut être commencer est en hypoglycémie
avec tout ce que je viens de rencontrer
en route
c'est donc un drôle de 76 non
choisissez très bien joué si c'est
propre
oui c'est propre lui c'est pas génial
mais vous c'est bonjour c'est ça qui est
bon pour toi et profanes disques ont
fait 1-1 espèce de cirque c'est pas vrai
et se dire que le vin il il ya d'abord
le nez 1
après il ya les joues après y'a
l'absortion puis à leur tour quand il
vaut la peine et les wagons temps de
retour il s'arrête à l'estomac et vous
produit c'est l'enfer mais il ya des
vins tout à fait merveilleux avec qui on
l'aude même par prendre une seconde
gorges est tellement on veut prendre
profité de la première
j'espère que ça va être l'occasion
bientôt
alors là ce peut dire une chose c'est
étonnant parce que le doigt ça a été un
des premiers rêve de ma vie parce que
j'avais il y avait un copain de mon père
qui venait passer les vacances à
bourgueil pas qu'ils étaient de
bourgueil mais il travaillait à paris et
fabriquer des des bateaux avec moi ont
fabriqué des bateaux avec des vieux
cuvier c'est à dire qu'on coupait une
cuve en deux violons mettez un mât on
expliquer ça mais ça l'est d'année en
année on était et on a beau le but
c'était de mettre le cuvier dans l'eau
et dans l'être les passagers d'aller
jusqu'à la loire et de la loire aller à
la mer est allé vers l'amérique
vous avez toujours l'évasion ce fleuve
qu'on suit qui vous fait rêver
il y avait aussi une chose qui me
faisait rêver c'est le bruit des trains
il y avait un train un bourgueil qui
était un train d'utilité local qu'ils
s'arrêtent calais qu'elle est à tour
c'était le petit train il y avait les
grands train qui passait à apport boulet
et on ne sait pas il y avait des dons
les entendait quand on y est arrivé
c'était un espèce de bruit d'enfer et
lointain s'étaient portés par le par le
vent on disait même que quand il allait
pleuvoir quand on entendait bien les
trains et mon père disait tiens c'est
une entre lyon je savais pas où était
lyon non ça me disait quelque chose
parce que c'est le prolongement tous ces
fleuves de de la loire mais lyon pour
moi ça une salle évoquées font encore la
région beaujolaise mais c'est mais
poussé ctad c'est peut-être quand on
nous demandait tout à l'heure pour quoi
j'ai fait ce métier c'est peut-être pour
voir le train des grandes lignes il ya
peut-être c'est peut-être aussi peu de
choses
[Musique]